could sgu actually make a return is it
practical
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
so recently did a video about stargate
universe and how joseph milose and brad
wright have both said that when the new
series of stargate comes if ever it
comes they really hope to have a
conclusion for the sgu storyline
we might actually get to go out and save
eli
now we have got some comics but that's
beta cannon that tells us what happened
after the sgu series finished but
if it didn't happen on screen for me it
didn't really happen so joseph malozy
brad wright i've really got free reign
to try and figure this out
but is it practical to do this could we
actually get the actors the or at very
least the main actors that are involved
in this to you to return
now i should say first of all i don't
think sdu is going to get serious i
don't think we're going to get a new 10
12 22 episode whatever series of target
universe
eli wallace
actually uh
eli's not here right now
okay okay whatever you guys think that i
did i swear you got the wrong guy do i
look like someone who'd be standing here
if i didn't already know everything
there is to know about you
yeah not really
right but i could see that as part of a
new series we could get maybe a double
episode or maybe even a short little
mini series of five six eight episodes
where sgu is resolved
so what are the actors doing now could
they return at very least for a couple
of episodes
basically where i'm going with this is
i've looked at their imdb i've looked at
projects that are coming up over the
next couple of years for the main actors
and i'm trying to see if any of them are
actually signed up to anything that
would restrict their ability to return
i'm sorry um
on the way to
to another planet
21 light years from here
i can't go i
i have things that we know about your
mother's condition
you just know everything don't you
we also know that you are currently
unemployed
and that your mother's medical coverage
is
an ongoing issue
so let's start with robert carlisle one
of the biggest and most successful
actors from stargate universe well he's
got a couple of projects in the running
at the moment but there are a couple of
movies
the performance is in production at the
moment and the blade artist is in early
production both of these movies will
last over the last 12 months or so but
i don't actually think either would stop
robert carlisle from returns to the sgu
at very least in a limited way and we
could see rush return to stargate
universe every intention you broke the
code
yes what
does it mean
shortly after the lucian elise attack
i wanted to tell you but i had to make
sure i knew everything about this before
i let it i should have killed you
i had the chance
louis ferreira colonel young now he's
had quite successful runs on things like
swat since stargate ended
but i had a look at what are his
projects coming up he has a quite a
small part in a movie called action
number one actually keep an eye open for
this i've read the synopsis going to mdb
and have a look it actually sounds
pretty cool
um he also is doing a mini series called
shogun but really it's not clear how big
a part he is in doing in that
but his career does seem to have slowed
down a little bit in the last 12 months
louis ferreira our colonel young could
most definitely 100 returned to the sgu
brian's j smith
lieutenant matthew now he has actually
done a lot of quite big projects and
appeared in a couple of series since i
remember one called the crossing which
got canceled after one series which was
really annoying it's actually quite like
that
um
but again i had a look at what he's
doing over the next 12 months he's doing
something called the class of 09 which
is a mini series which again looks like
quite an interesting project and he's
doing a movie the treatment which is in
post-production at the moment he's
actually already done the work for that
so again
brian j smith is not signed up to any
major series or many major franchise so
i don't see any reason why we couldn't
see lieutenant matthew return to this gu
right
i i think i want my lawyer to look it
over first and by lawyer i assume you
mean mother so we'll just agree then
that i will call you
but what about one of our favorite
characters
eli
well david blue actually is on the
internet a lot he um he's on so called
twitch and he does a lot of gaming
things or whatever as well but he is
still working as an actor um but the
only thing actually on imdb moments is a
movie called death camp which is just
completed it's in post-production i
don't see any other projects that he's
signed up for at the moment so having
eli return to the sgu is not only a
possibility i actually imagine it would
be very very easy and to be honest if
they wanted to do something quite
restricted or if they only brought eli
back and if that's what the story
dictated i actually think fans would be
okay with that i know personally i would
i'm not that invested and not that
bothered about a lot of these other
characters i'm going to talk about a
couple more in a minute
but if they saved eli i'd be quite happy
i'd be very happy if actually they saved
him and he returned and became a regular
whatever new series they had because he
was always an actor i really liked and
that boy has worked out um he has saw
himself that he's not the chubby little
comedy fellow he once was
so let's talk about a couple of actors
that either i'm not bothered about
returning or just won't and there's one
name obviously you're gonna know
what
why didn't you pull that trigger
there's no predicting how someone's
gonna react in a pressure situation
panic sets in people freeze
it happens
but not to you
something got inside your head
what
i think i died
jamil walker smith played uh master
sergeant greet now he was a character i
always actually really loved because he
was always a bit dangerous and a bit
crazy he has done several movies and
appeared in a few series at the moment
he's appearing in a little short run um
in the rookie he's appeared in two or
three episodes
um he has done something called steal
that horse which is in development at
the moment um he's done chuck hank and
the san diego twins which is in
post-production at the moment as well
so again he's not signed up to any major
franchise he could very easily return
and to be honest he's a character i
would like to see return because he had
a bit of an edge to him
somebody who i'm not bothered about
returning is chloe
ellie's oh nice i can't really say this
woman's name
elise levesque
elise levesque
she has got several projects and she's a
writer director and producer now as well
um but she's actually not signed up for
anything but you know what i don't care
if she's or not she's very forgettable
from the series and i don't care if she
returns not even a little bit
another one who i don't care about
returning is elena huffman now she
played the linen and tamara johansen she
was the doctor in sgu um she again had a
very forgettable role they had that
whole thing with young didn't care
she's quite she's a very beautiful woman
fair enough but if she doesn't return
nobody would notice and i personally
don't think anyone would really care
ming nawa
didn't have a massive role in sgu don't
list you know let's go wrong she has
become very popular since obviously she
had her part in the uh marvel agents of
shield which she was brilliant in and
obviously now she's just done the book
of boba fett and she signed up to appear
in a couple of other series on along the
star wars line her character in that
series is absolutely fantastic and she
is the woman that never ages she's
incredibly beautiful she's still as
gorgeous as she was 20 years ago in sgu
and any other series she's done
and it's unbelievable a woman is well
into her 50s
she will not be returned to the sgu i do
not see her being able to she's signed
up to a major franchise for star wars
she's not just doing bob effect but
she's doing other series as well so
we're not going to see ming now in
return and to be honest though it's not
going to be a big problem because like i
said her role wasn't that big
but how could they explain why certain
characters have just not returned well
to be honest it wouldn't be hard
come on
mr wallace
more than a decade has gone by since sgu
ended there was a decade of the destiny
getting continuously batted we could say
that you know stasis pods failed or
something else there's lots of ways they
could write it in that one two three
four maybe characters return and the
rest sadly don't make it
[Music]
you're a good man
get this done
i want to see you on the other side
right right
[Music]
[Music]
it wouldn't be difficult to write this
in and you know it would be really
logical so
let's see what happens we are going to
get a conclusion to the sgu according to
brad wright so let's fingers crossed
that actually a lot of the actors are
available and this really seriously
could happen very easily
so if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out also
you could consider becoming a fully
fledged side tracker hit the join button
it really supports the channel helps us
keep going
as always please stay safe get in the
comments tell me exactly what you think
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you